I just got a preview of some of the
things that Microsoft is going to be
talking about at CES this year now you
may think of Microsoft as the maker of
windows which runs on PCs whereas they
don't do so well on phones or slates or
what have you Microsoft is addressing
that in their vision of the future
Windows runs on everything from phones
to slates to desktops and laptops and
it's all the same Windows now to make
this happen what they're doing is
creating special versions of Windows
that run on the same hardware currently
used for phones chips made by the likes
of nvidia texas instruments and the big
one is qualcomm they demonstrated
windows running on all of these chips
and it's a cool demo but what it really
means is that in the future you'll be
able to run Windows on very small
low-power lightweight devices so you're
tired of Windows Microsoft has news for
you Windows is coming to a lot more
gadgets in the near future